[Música]
se cierra el Grifo al nuevo carruso el
canciller Alemán ha frenado el proyecto
de gaseoducto nordstring 2
economía y a la agencia Federal de redes
que retire el informe sobre la seguridad
del suministro para asegurarnos de que
el gaseo ducto no puede certificarse en
este momento y sin esta certificación el
nordestrin 2 no puede operar
el nuevo gaseoducto atraviesa el mar
Báltico y tiene capacidad para duplicar
el suministro de gas desde Rusia
Alemania conectando directamente ambos
países la infraestructura esta lista
desde el año pasado pendiente de la
aprobación de la autoridad reguladora
alemana el proyecto está en el centro
en Europa por su impacto en los hogares
de la región el 61% de las necesidades
energéticas de la Unión Europea se cubre
con importación
de las importaciones de crudo y el 41
ciento de las de gas
las perspectivas de un conflicto armado
con Rusia y las duras sanciones de
occidente han disparado el mercado de
futuros del gas en un momento en que las
facturas energéticas ya están en máximos
el Primer Ministro británico reprocha
que Europa no haya buscado alternativas
a los suministros rusos tras la crisis
de crimea de 2014
en el precio del gas al que las
economías europeas son tan vulnerables
es una consecuencia del fracaso de
liberarnos de esa dependencia Esto es lo
que tenemos que hacer ahora cortar el
cordón umbilical que nos ata al norte